-My first guest is
an Emmy-nominated actor
and Emmy-winning director
for his fantastic work
on the critically acclaim
television series "Ozark."
This weekend he is hosting
"Saturday Night Live"
with musical guest
Morgan Wallen.
I'm thrilled that he can
actually be here
in the studio tonight.
Please welcome, Jason Bateman!
-♪ This is Jason Bateman ♪
♪ This is Jason Bateman ♪
♪ This is Jason
"Silver Spoons" ♪
"It's Your Move,"
"Arrested Development" Bateman ♪
♪ This is Jason Bateman ♪
♪ This is
Jason Bateman ♪
♪ This is Jason "Silver Spoons,"
♪ It's Your Move" ♪
-Look at that, yeah.
This is it. This is --
-Pretty pathetic.
-This is -- [ Laughs ]
This is the best we can --
Jason, this is the best
we can do. We just --
-You goose all the applause
later, right, in post?
-No, this is it.
-This is it?
-That is totally it, yeah.
I'm so happy you're here.
You look fantastic.
-I wore my baby cord burgundy
for you today
because we're in studio.
-Thank you.
It is a gorgeous suit.
-If it was Zoom,
it would be my PJs.
-Yeah, that's right.
Have you been this dressed up
in a while?
-No, and this has got to be
back in about a half hour, so --
[ Laughter ]
-I understand.
Jason, you're hosting
"Saturday Night Live" again.
You hosted -- you hosted --
-15 years ago.
-Is that right?
-Yeah, it feels like longer
because I loved it so much
and wanted to do it
every day afterwards.
As you know, it's such
an amazing --
cords do not move on
this couch.
[ Laughter ]
-There's no slide.
There's no slide --
-My entire underwear
is inside me right now.
[ Laughter ]
I'll work five-person audience.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'll get it.
-This is better --
[ Cheering ]
This is better than
my monologue.
This is unbelievable.
-It's so casual.
I saw you on the stool.
I'm like,
I said to the guy
in the dressing room,
"When do you guys start?"
[ Laughter ]
He said,
"No, we're doing it now."
I go, "He's sitting on a stool."
-Yeah, it's a cool medium now.
-It's so casual.
-It's just casual. You're like,
"Yeah, we're just hanging out
like buddies, talking.
-Jimmy's just --
he's just like a nice
old pair of shoes, isn't he?
-[ Laughs ] I'll take that.
I love that, man.
I have to talk "Ozark"
because I haven't talk to you
since you started "Ozark,"
which is bizarre.
-Do you have notes?
We're locked, you know.
[ Laughter ]
The stuff you've seen
we can't change.
-Okay, yeah, no,
my only note is that --
it's a thank-you note
to say thank you for --
That's one of the best things
I've ever seen.
-Oh, man, thank you.
You are phenomenal
in this show, dude.
[ Applause ]
Unbelievable.
-You're goosing that.
-No, we don't.
We're not goosing.
-You'll goose that.
You will goose that.
-Not gonna goose that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There it is.
-That's the one you wanted.
♪♪
And now you've got a band thing.
Oh, my God.
Hey, all right.
Questlove has seen everything.
You've seen all the episodes
and everything.
-Absolutely.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-I'm on season --
-Thank you.
-...season two, episode three.
But let me -- no, no, Jason,
let me tell you why.
Let me tell you why.
I don't --
-You're busy.
-No.
I don't want it to end.
I don't want to keep -- because
I know it's going to end.
-I'll buy that.
-It's like when you read
a good book.
When I was reading
Steve Martin's book,
"Born Standing Up,"
I was so mad that it was
going to come to an end,
I'm like, ah!
I just want to keep reading
this.
It is so good.
You are phenomenal.
Everybody --
-Really, really good,
good group of people.
And the writers, I don't
know how they keep
escalating the danger
without killing us
or putting us in jail.
I mean, we make as many mistakes
as you possibly can without
getting killed or incarcerated.
-Yeah.
-And we've got more in store
for this --
-Also you're directing, too,
and just --
you're crushing --
Dude, you're --
do you enjoy that part?
-I love it, yeah.
-...another job for you?
I mean, no. I mean, I guess
there's a part of me
that's sort of masochistic,
you know.
I like the acting.
But it's so comfortable for me
that I'm able to observe --
like, I'm keenly aware that
like,
if that camera had to move
right, now I'd probably wait
to finish my answer
until it's settled.
I'm always looking
to, like, help the crew.
Because as a little kid,
the crew members would
always be like,
"Buddy, you got help me out.
I got to get the boom
over there.
Can you just hold your line?"
I'm like, "Sure, sir."
So I'm a real people pleaser
when it comes to the work
on the set, so I like to,
you know, facilitate shots
and stuff that work.
So I like the acting,
but I like to pile on
with the other stuff and make
the crew's day short
or the actor's day short.
-Yeah.
Just stays fun
and stays exciting, electric.
-Yeah, I love it a bunch.
But this next year --
we're two weeks into shooting.
It's going to be the last year,
but we're going to do 14
instead of 10 episodes,
and we're going
to split them up in two,
so it will be seven and seven.
So it will really be like season
four and season five,
but they're shorter.
I don't --
-Then it's all over.
-We do land the plane
in a very satisfactory way,
but...
-You're happy with it?
-Yeah.
-What do you think it is about
-- because I have a theory,
why people like Marty.
Why they like your character.
-He has got incredible hair.
[ Laughter ]
-He really is
a good-looking dude, yeah.
-I say that to you because
look at you.
-Look at you. Thank you.
-Right?
-I got this from Amazon
last week.
-If we just agitate it
a little bit up top.
-A little messed -- but still
under control a little bit.
-I can see your lace, though,
is coming up just a little bit.
No, he's us.
I mean, hopefully, you know?
He's, you know,
a middle-aged dude
trying to get it --
get on with it
with his kids and his wife
and keep them alive
and be a provider.
And then he -- you know,
and he's probably a little bit
dumber than he thinks he is,
so he backs into
some bad decisions, but he
thinks they're good decisions.
And then he's got to kind of pay
the price for cutting corners
and stuff like that.
-I think it's also --
it's because I think
he's honest.
He's honest, even with the --
saying the awful truth.
I mean, like, "All right,
you really want to know
what happens?
How the sausage is made?
This goes that, that and that
and this and that, that's it."
And you go, I can't believe
you just said that.
-The money laundering stuff?
-Yeah, all that stuff.
-Yeah, we try not to get
the audience into the weeds
too much with that,
because it's hard to --
I think -- the only thing
I've been able to absorb
about money laundering
in three years is that
you need fake receipts.
If you can get fake receipts --
Guys, we can all just --
we can all retire tomorrow.
-Just, tips.
There you go. Fake receipts.
-Fake receipts. That's it.
-Just some tips from
Jason Bateman. That's it.
Earlier this week we had
Nick Kroll on the show
and we played a game called
"Guess the Impression."
-That is a funny man.
-He's a funny dude.
So we just had names come up.
We did not practice
the impression.
And then I got --
your name came up,
and so I had to think of,
how do I do an impression
of you?
-Oh, no. This is hurtful.
This is going to be hurtful.
-No, it's fun. It's all --
-Impressions are not
complimentary, Jimmy.
-Yes.
-No, they're not.
-It's an homage,
not an impression.
-An homage.
It's a beautiful pronunciation.
-Thank you.
-Damn it.
Where are you from?
[ Laughter ]
Are you from Montreal?
-I'm from Montreal, yeah.
I'm not even from France,
it's from Montreal.
From -- yeah.
I want to show the impression,
and just --
I don't even know why I want
to show the impression.
-You did me?
-I think I did you.
I think I did a decent
impression of you.
I don't know.
Quest, did you see it?
-I did not see it.
-You did not see it.
Yeah, we'll see it
when we come back.
More with Jason Bateman
We're gonna see it, but --
it's close, the impression.